this video is brought to you by
manscape.com
i've moved into my first home gotten
engaged and gained a new family member
so i guess i can say that one piece has
been there for some of the most
important moments of my life i can't
wait to continue this story with you all
but until then as always i've been
totally not mark and thank you so much
for watching
[Music]
ladies gentlemen and that technicolored
rainbow in between we are back and for
those of you that didn't have to wait
the two years for this continuation of
my review series what's it like being
god's best friend to be quite honest
when i said those parting words way back
when i never in my wildest dreams could
have imagined almost two years passing
between episodes in this series but then
again that is the nature of wano and one
piece i guess and as of running this
video it's still technically not over
but given that oda decided to make the
raided onigishima longer than some of
the arcs in the series i figured it was
perfect for its own video or should i
say
videos reviewing the rated onigishima
was a titanic task and due to this arc
being incredibly dense and the anime
having covered almost exactly half of it
i thought it would be nice if i made
sure that this first return video was
primed safe and ready for the anime
onlys watching today meaning this week i
am covering the first half of okushima's
raid and concluding it once and for all
next week so with that out of the way
once again i'm totally not mark and
these are my first impressions of
thoughts on and review for the crazy
chaotic magical legendary and long
overdue continuation on this wonderful
voyage i am of course speaking of the
illustrious one pieces raid on
onigishima
[Music]
oh boy does it feel good to be back back
on the shores of wano or should i say
onigishima primed and ready to tackle
the oncoming war between some of the
highest bounties in the land of one
piece but i must say the landscape of
the one piece online community has
changed drastically since i last added
to this series almost two years ago and
with that said i'll be honest comes with
a level of wavering uncertainty
concerning how best i should share my
thoughts on this material after all the
writing onigishima is
controversial and if there's one thing
anime focused content creators want to
avoid it's
what the hell is that on one hand i am
massively excited to dive back into one
piece it's a story i've loved from the
very beginning and the thought of once
again getting the chance to express my
thoughts on the story i enjoy with all
of you is invigorating however on the
other hand this will be the first time
i've written a review for a section of
the story while also being acutely aware
of how the community surrounding this
specific portion online has been
receiving it with a sizable sect of the
one piece community banding together
under the banner of voicing their
distaste and dislike for the raid itself
with some of the most popular figures
getting hate for simply sharing their
honest opinions online concerning it now
this sort of
stop that this type of division or
lose-lose scenario would have bothered
the mark i was 625 days ago but since
then i have undergone a metamorphosis a
journey a quest in reviewing and
disagreeing with so many of the world's
largest online fandoms that my bounty
within the online anime community at
this point must be larger than even
luffy's in his world and so with that
said let's try to have fun with this one
okay like always i love like and dislike
elements of any story i only ask for
your time and understanding as i try to
explain my thought process behind why i
might feel one way or the other about
something so without further ado let's
go through this piece by piece kicking
off
at the beginning the raid commences this
raid is bananas has some of the most
breakneck frantic pacing towards the
start in a good way and presented me
with scenes that gave me chills
furthermore the anime managed to
supersede my wildest and highest
expectations for this story managing to
present the material in a fashion that i
found not only resonant as a fan of the
series but utterly gorgeous as an artist
and human being which is why i want to
give the anime its own section later so
look forward to that however this wasn't
to say that i didn't have concerns for
how this raid might be structured and
presented in this story if the pop
culture machine is anything to go by
these days whether it be in the east or
in the west great stories with action
interwoven into the dna of the
storytelling can be both terrific and
revolutionary one minute and utterly
devastating in another when it comes to
grand epic battles of good versus evil
one aspect above all else that i always
like to make sure is there is that of an
emotional through line a goal story arc
or target to be kept in the reader's
eyes and mind as the story in action
marches onward it's difficult to compare
juano's right in onigima to anything
that's come before it due to its
tremendous scale and length but when it
came to one piece as marine forward i
think that arc did a masterful job of
creating and following an emotional
through line too providing a clear and
obvious narrative thread that served to
deliver that ark's most poignant moment
satisfying us as readers and watchers in
the process in one-o while structurally
similar some chess pieces are different
others are missing and even a few have
been promoted since that outing in
marine ford all those years ago and
despite the goal for our main characters
being ace in marineford it's more so a
battle for the future of the one-piece
world as we know it hoisted on the
shoulders of the older and present
generations luffy's newer and younger
generation is afforded a luxury they
otherwise can't enjoy in wano in
marineford while whitebeard and the
older generations were allowed to take
the reins and sing their swansong they
also in the process took care of the
battle's logistics at any loose ends
that might require seeing to freeing up
luffy to focus on the emotional through
line of the battle without needing to
worry about other aspects that were less
interesting needless to say this was by
design and in wano oda made sure to see
to that aspect of the story too now
luffy's generation has to take the world
for themselves and lead the charge now
luffy has to carry the war he's the
leader and surprisingly it works
elegantly naturally and extremely well
within the themes and framework of the
series and arc itself all at once one
piece again highlighting the stark
contrast between who they once were
versus who they are now and want to be
furthermore something the onagushima ray
did masterfully well was that it created
a prologue to the coming war or battle
that truly captured my imagination and
set the stage for the coming conflict
beyond what my wildest dreams could have
prepared me for having spent so long
being beaten down by wano's despair
bottomless corruption misfortune and
torture only forced to get a taste of
what it once was in odin's flashback
before being stabbed in the back left
feeling isolated and alone looking out
at the sea filled with possibilities of
a raid failing before it even began once
luffy and co arrived my hype level
rivaled that of marine fort but we
haven't started the fight yet and before
we do oda needs to inform us of a few
things we must first understand the
arena marine ford had an iconic arena
that played a vital role in determining
the flow of the battle as well as the
obstacles it presented and so too did
wano's
an island with a skull-shaped structure
housed within a number of different
themed floors filled with their own
unique battles and enemies that need
their own unique approaches and atop
this demonic structure the ultimate goal
and rematch awaiting luffy
kaido now allied with big mom it seemed
simple enough and in the earliest stages
it was oda did a wonderful job
establishing the layout of the area
establishing what teams are where and
even created a natural means for the
gang to infiltrate the building in
disguises manifested by kinemon and from
there our straw had splinter into their
own respective squadrons to tackle the
relevant floors freeing up the main
entree luffy and those in his follow to
contest kaido and big mom atop this
structure as things are conceptually
this is an exciting and fun way to
present the coming conflict it has built
in tension with them sneaking into the
structure without actually going in all
guns blazing which is absolutely what
luffy does later we have our gang split
up for good reasons we have a rough idea
of what this area is structured like and
we know what the goal is to take back
wano from kaido to liberate its people
and with momo still in the clutches of
kendura the traitor and that cockroach
orochimaru's still knocking about
there's plenty for us to anticipate as
the battle commences
[Music]
now i know cousin it from the addams
family is real
yas queen squad goals but it's time to
get trimmed up with manscape's new
lawnmower 4.0 electric trimmer you get
this wonderful waterproof shaver and
more when you purchase their new
performance package 4.0 along with it
comes the crop preserver ball deodorant
and the crop reviver ball toning spray
to keep you smelling fresh all damn day
but did you know that for a limited time
only when you pick up the performance
package 4.0 you also get two free gifts
the shed travel bag and the manscaped
anti-chafing boxers these cooling boxer
briefs might actually be one of the
coolest parts of this collection what's
the point in manscaping your bits like a
pro if you're just going to throw on
some rags afterwards not only are
manscapes boxers extra comfy but they
have fancy crop cooling technology to
keep you cool and dry all day long the
fabric's super soft and comes in a wide
range of sizes all the way up to triple
xl and what's neat is that you get to
opt into their peak hygiene plan which
means you'll get a new pair every cycle
straight to your door if all that sounds
good then head over to manscape.com and
use promo code not mark 20
for 20 off free international shipping
and two free gifts underwear
to your door your paws will thank you
bye
but take a look at that iceberg if you
don't turn now we'll hit it
so much for that iceberg
[Music]
okay look let's let's slow down a bit
and just take stock of where we are i
think early on i was most impressed with
oda's ability to create comedic moments
within the seriousness and chaos of the
broader raid itself showing the gang
react to luffy going to make things
worse and zoro going after luffy to
witch the gang remarks he's only gonna
get lost rooting all of this of course
in the character of the series is built
upon was a genius and lovely idea
similarly to how some comedians deliver
phenomenally dramatic performances like
robin williams in goodwill hunting and
mrs doubtfire oda leverages his comedic
chops to help avoid this battle becoming
onenote and downtrodden by the gravitas
of the occasion also again and i'm sure
many people might have overlooked this
moment but completely driven by
character there's a short but brilliant
exchange between luffy and zoro that i
absolutely adored i never really thought
to speak of this aspect when i was
reviewing the series a number of years
ago however having spoken to fans of the
zorro character recently i've personally
found a new appreciation for the
character myself the duo of zorro and
luffy is exceptional across this series
and despite one of them being stoic to
the point of silence on a number of
occasions they have perhaps some of the
best chemistry in the series and
fittingly don't share too many exchanges
to share that zorro is a formidable
character one that offers a lot in the
way of brawn and ability to the straw
hats but what i think is often
overlooked regarding him is his
effectiveness as the backbone of the
greater straw hat crew themselves a few
weeks ago i spoke on how much i adored
the battle luffy shared with usop during
water 7. and a main component as to why
i found that to be so resonant and
effective in essence spawned from the
realism and sense of division it created
amongst the crew themselves and few
contributed to that feeling more so than
zorro himself for he was the one who
stood in luffy's corner backing up every
uncertain but stern decision he made or
was forced to make towards usopp and
when usopp wanted to get back to the
straw hats luffy was willing to accept
usop's excuses if it meant he could get
his friend back however zorro made sure
luffy stood his ground to get the
apology he was owed and this i think
makes zoro the perfect first mate the
perfect second in command and compliment
to luffy's boundless ambition helping
him to remain focused in moments where
he might be unwieldy and to back him up
whatever it takes when the moment calls
for it and chapter 980 has a wonderful
moment that echoes that very aspect of
their dynamic with zorro having chased
after luffy who has now just blown his
cover due to the indulgence of the
ruling class and soldiers in response
zoro complains but once he figures out
the situation and the motivation behind
it this big brotherly bond is in full
force once again
[Music]
and switching gears from that dynamic we
even get moments where kid himself goes
face to face with rivals of his from the
very generation he belongs to alongside
luffy with excuses like do you really
think you tipped the balance in favor of
yourselves against one of the four
emperors being the order of the day and
once again in line with each of their
characters it's not by chance the
rebellious thought leaders found
themselves aligned against kaido those
with ambition that genuinely want to
grab the world by the reigns and steer
it in the right direction are fighting
kaido and those two scared to challenge
the status quo are stuck beneath his
dogmatic and tyrannical thumb it's a
subtle but again very effective aspect
of the villain's characterization that
helps to create an obvious and easy side
to root for however with all of this
good stuff there are some small issues
that eventually cascade into much larger
ones for me as i read on and it all
starts with the conveyance within the
raid itself so what do i mean well
dotted throughout this raid are
instances of exposition text from oda
directly to us where in lieu of
demonstrating a particular group or
character's positioning he just tells us
this struck me as strange normally one
piece is meticulous in its setup and
desire to let the story do the talking
we don't need to be told where they are
by some disembodied voice or narration
bubble we normally find this out through
context clues in the story like when
sanji went to the sea train in water 7
or visual cues like in arlong park or
alabasta looking at stories like skypia
or even massive events like marineford
characters establishing shots and the
story's flow would fill us in on the
details normally however here in wano
for some reason it doesn't and i think i
might know why
having spent the entire story on the
wano mainland getting to know that
region and the area now having moved to
another island one that has multiple
layers or floors filled with countless
characters many of which are newly
introduced during the wano arc itself
all duking it out in honestly at this
point very similar styles of battle now
oda finds himself in a situation where
he wants to have for example a pleasure
hall when we as an audience don't know
what they look like all too well we
don't know where it is in relation to
the rest of the crew fighting and that's
the problem furthermore with everyone on
every floor fighting that too creates
environments that look rather similar
understanding this oda later introduces
much more unique types of fighting as
well as different targets for the gang
to hit on each of the respective floors
but even including the most diverse
examples for me
it didn't help all that much impul down
handled this issue fantastically and i
honestly thought it had a similar
problem to overcome however it did
overcome this by creating easy to convey
visual identifiers for each floor of the
compound respectively however i will
also make the caveat that impel down
didn't have the issue of having to dart
back and forth between different
perspectives it just focused on luffy
really and this all isn't to say by the
way that this issue bothered me
tremendously at this point however it is
i think the first sign of a much more
all-consuming issue i encountered later
on towards the middle of the raid itself
in the meantime i was still enthralled
by the feverish pacing and the intrigue
each newly revealed ruffle to this
battle potentially offered like this one
yeah marco's here
this i did not see coming and i wondered
why seeing as i should have known he was
on his way in some capacity but whatever
about that he'll have his own moments
later but now we gotta clear the red
carpet for the main men of the hour odin
or should i say the internet's new
favorite yamato
[Music]
yamato is a character that's grown in
popularity enormously since they're
unveiling and to be honest i was blown
away to see that they were revealed so
early on in this story i had forgotten
how early they were introduced so now we
get the offspring of kaido running about
in opposition to his father channeling
the spirit of odin himself all the while
sort of acting like odin in many
respects
it's an interesting ruffle to the story
and again led me to reconsider how key
events in this conclusion to this epic
battle might play out in the future and
just as that happened
yeah this is something of a trend for
orochi this battle and given how awful
of a person he is i'm kind of here for
it i kind of want to see him die again
and again and again and while we're
focusing on kaido's section of the
ongoing skirmish i think it's important
to touch on a vital aspect of the story
a narrative thread that extends far
beyond this raid and even this very arc
i am of course talking about kozuki
the quest to find oneself isn't a story
one piece tries to avoid in any capacity
striving for your dreams and staying
true to who you are are of course the
core tenants of many jump stories
including one piece we've seen it with
the likes of nami and arlon park robin
and his lobby more famously and now we
see it through the character of momo in
guano across perhaps the longest journey
to find oneself in this series having
come into focus for us within what we
thought at the time was a side plot in
punk hazard he's introduced as a
regretful the shame scared and misguided
young boy and yet despite the less than
ideal circumstances that befell both he
and those looking over him thanks to the
kindness of our main crew despite
finding himself in the clutches of the
very man that scares him more than any
other on this planet
he's able to show his growth and resolve
as a character proclaiming his namesake
in defiance of what kaido stands for
demonstrating to everyone within earshot
and of course us reading and watching
that he is no longer the sniveling child
he once was but now a strong
and capable young man it's a stunning
payoff i thought to what was a long and
winding character arc it pay off that
alongside others were all concentrated
and confined to only the beginning of
this raid and i honestly think that's
remarkable a little while ago i made a
video called the day dragon ball died
and in this i tried to describe why i
found that to quite frankly be the case
in at least one meaningful capacity and
that very capacity being that i thought
the fighting was no longer a driving
force for the narrative and while i have
my issues with one piece's choices in
conveyance there's no denying the sheer
volume of compelling character focused
and narratively driven story beats that
occupy and populate the pages of this
manga chapter after chapter when i say
that reading this week to week versus
reading it all in one go is a massively
different experience i want to emphasize
that that is actually the case
chills man absolute chills it's what we
have character driven stories for we've
followed these troubled individuals
seeing their journey their past their
ups their tragic downs and naturally
their goals with one final albeit
massive dragon shaped obstacle standing
before them it's a standoff worthy of
the time dedicated to it odo wants us to
take notice and recognize this as a
monumental moment in this story and it
absolutely felt that way for me as i
read it i apologize also if my reactions
to this story at this moment sound
unwieldy and somewhat frantic if it
feels like i'm dashing from one awesome
moment to the next sharing my thoughts
that's because i kind of am and it's by
design in reality i'm trying to capture
something of a glimpse of what it might
have been like to discuss this with me
as i was reading the early portion with
grand moment after grand moment
prophetic reunitings after massive set
pieces that conclude with amazing group
shots ready to catapult us into the next
exciting sequence all of this takes
center stage without delay it is frantic
in every sense of the word and in a
brilliant way that's both exciting and
appropriate for the story being told
there's no negatives really at this
point to speak of outside of that minor
conveyance issue however still at the
forefront of my mind at this point was
one thing
kaido versus luffy the rematch a long
time has passed since their last
encounter both in real life and sort of
in the one piece story maybe not i don't
know and in the back of my mind despite
enjoying all the pageantry and one piece
awesomeness i was eagerly awaiting the
moment that i was certain would change
the story forever i could not wait for
this rematch
[Music]
okay so let's set the scene kaido's on
the roof luffy's on his way to the roof
to challenge kaido and between luffy and
the big dragon himself stands a number
of formidable foes that are all being
ordered to stop him no matter the cost
it's an easy to understand structure for
this challenge and honestly i'm hyped
but perhaps more importantly in many
ways this feels like the ultimate test
for the straw hat pirates themselves
along this difficult ascent up to the
roof luffy and his gang encounter a
colorful litany of enemies that at any
other point in the story could have
spelt the end for their little crew
however when they point out as each of
them drops off one after another to buy
time for luffy
that was a long time ago encountering
obstacles that would rival the likes of
oars zoro slices through him as if it
were nothing special luffy assumes gear
4 screams things are different now not
just a battle cry but a promise to us as
viewers and readers that our time spent
with these characters has served a
purpose we believe in luffy when he says
this no longer the crew that would run
instead they have now become something
worthy themselves of running from and i
think that's something not many manga
get to enjoy certainly not like one
piece does anyway it's like every turn
of the page i'm greeted with another
reminder of their character progression
whether it be through sanji jinbe nami
or robin who all get their own chance to
shine in this conflict let me add but
more on that next week with each of them
making it their mission to conserve
luffy's strength to hold the line with
each respective enemy they encounter
it's simple but if you don't get the
simple stuff right then the more
complicated stuff later on either
doesn't matter or comes off as
pretentious
i'm gonna come clean for a second
because i personally haven't looked at a
lot of the anime and even within this
video i've only really taken a look at
less than a handful however one thing i
did notice while i was watching those
episodes was how well oda's manga pages
with their numerous panels end up
translating as a storyboard for a given
animation this was a massive upside i
saw for those watching this anime in the
past and indeed with later portions of
this arc that i will struggle to get
through in this review and manga that
doesn't happen to be the case however
with this samurai fight oda knocked it
out of the park pages felt much less
cluttered when the time came for the
action more interesting layouts started
to make themselves known and the action
could breathe there was even a moment in
the short exchange that made me audibly
gassed i'm serious i gasped and it was
for this
chapter 1000
chapter 1000 was a landmark event i
touted early on in my one piece journey
that i said time and again i wanted to
be present for that it wasn't every day
a series like one piece comes along let
alone reaches 1 000 chapters and this
might be my favorite point in the early
battle for all the aspects of it that
i've praised prior i think this sequence
is the moment where the storylines in
the battle felt the most in sync with
each other the chaos takes a breath and
for the first time it truly feels like a
structure i can immerse myself entirely
within and it's achieved through
contrast during this section there are a
multitude of povs to consider however
really there are only two main ones at
this time that we should focus on
luffy's and the samurais each has their
unique tasks and both feed into the
effectiveness of each other naturally
with regards the samurai's struggle
against kaido understanding that this
situation with them is worsening is made
all the more tense as we know luffy will
arrive at any moment to help their
worsening situation the drama and
tenseness of the occasion is made all
the more palpable when contrasted with
the lighthearted blitz luffy section
provides unlike the samurai scene that
are terrified and standing their ground
luffy just runs straight past everyone
in his way to beeline it to the roof to
tango with kaido however while these two
scenes have key differences used for the
purpose of contrast they're also
importantly similar they both
demonstrate a group of friends allies or
warriors standing by one another to help
each other achieve their goal wear the
samurai stand by each other so to do the
straw hats stand by their captain it's
uplifting within both scenes of course
however when one comes out in top
another doesn't
this discovery atop the structure is
shocking watching as kinemon leaves his
dying wish to luffy the upbeat and
somewhat lighthearted nature of luffy's
scramble to the top becomes overshadowed
by the weight of this new responsibility
getting the chance to sit back and watch
as luffy and the major players in this
conflict converge before kaido and big
bomb was a thrilling moment i love these
calmer instances before the storm and i
think that while the manga did a great
job with this scene i don't think i've
seen a better adaptation committed to
any other anime because bagumi shitani
demonstrated how impressive she was as
an anime director with episode 1015
covering this very material and while i
will most definitely be covering it
later on in this video i need to mention
it at this point too it's just that damn
good
the fight that takes place here is great
too perhaps some of the best action
paneling i've seen from oda in quite
some time a prominent complaint i've had
for this raid that i will most
definitely be addressing later on as its
cluttered nature increases hindering my
personal ability in understanding and
enjoying what's been shown to me has
been the paneling itself cluttered as it
is however with this fight and indeed
the samurai fight leading up to it there
are large panels everywhere interesting
layouts and compelling set pieces
flashing to and fro from characters like
kids zorro and luffy as they each try
their hand at toppling the unstoppable
kaido it's a compelling set of
circumstances one that's allowed to
breathe and shine through these very
pages one that's outcome determines the
future of not just buono but the
one-piece world as it stands all they
have to do is keep the pressure on
this is bad but it is hype it's so cool
and things are immeasurably tense and
while things are tense at this very
moment let's take a step back and talk
about some of the people and moments
that helped to turn this
into this
the anime despite covering the manga in
this video one thing that's impossible
to ignore is the sheer quality of the
anime adaptation in this arc week after
week spectacular scenes from muano are
paraded around social media and as the
show has reached the rooftop and the
quantity of action increased so too has
the quality of output from the animators
on board this wonderful adaptation after
struggling to maintain its reputation
post time skip reaching some remarkable
lows in dressrosa the anime has found
itself revitalized while it of course
can't hit the consistency of a 12 to 24
episode seasonal anime it has
confidently cemented itself as the best
looking long format show on tv right now
the dramatic increase in quality is the
result of a number of staff changes that
have slotted together to form the
backbone of this production the biggest
change comes in the form of the show's
series director this is the person in
charge of the entire production both as
a creative decision maker and final
supervisor meaning they have the last
word on every aspect of the production
and it was tatsuya nagamine who took
over this role perhaps best known these
days for directing dragon ball super
broly and heralding the visual upgrade
the super tv series received in its
universe survival arc in a similar vein
one of the very first things nagamine
did in this role was overhaul the show's
composite meaning how the original
drawings are treated their colours their
lighting effects and even the way the
line work looks he ousted the previous
company sanko productions who had been
with the show for 20 years and instead
replaced them with the asahi production
one of the most beloved compositing
studios in japan and the group who
defined the look of the one piece movies
gold and stampede led by naoyuki wada
the anime found itself with thick inky
line work bloom and intense lighting
creative camera work like depth of field
and a more bombastic approach to the way
the cast powers were displayed guided by
the series director it helped bring the
anime up to modern standards that
allowed even the most basic of scenes to
shine brighter than they had ever done
before however the series director role
requires more than just overseeing the
finishing of episodes it's an intensive
role that sees nagamine looking over and
often providing corrections for every
episode storyboard it is so much work so
much so in fact that the wano arc
introduced two co-series directors in
the form of kohei kureta and ayakomaki
two of the series most beloved episode
directors with these exceptionally
talented staff members leading the
production a show with the scope of one
piece finally received the necessary
manpower to ensure its success and a
series can't be made with three people
of course and so a huge number of
animators are required to bring the show
to life this is where the production
manager comes in they're the person in
charge of gathering talent for each
respective episode and as a result can
be just as important in determining the
show's quality than the series director
themselves a man by the name of tetsuji
akahori plays this role on one piece and
arguably deserves the biggest praise for
their role in elevating wano itself
akahori is a huge one-piece fan and has
routinely gone out of his way to bring
the finest animators and directors into
the fold he has reached out to overseas
talents on twitter bringing in the likes
of vincent chansard and glasro in the
latter of which we even managed to rope
into one of our redraw videos recently
and also brought in the likes of shu
sugita and bahi jd two of the best
animators working today together with
nagamine and the production assistant
hayato tokita akohori takes a lot of
time planning out where best to use
these staff members to ensure they have
the biggest impact he has likewise
looked inward at toy's own staff to help
foster talent from within promoting the
likes of too young sir to animation
director and series veteran katsumi
ishizuka to the role of action
storyboard artist this has all resulted
in an atmosphere where everyone's
looking to do their best and their
efforts are actually rewarded for
example yasunori koyama a director who
has been with the series for many many
years without making too much of an
impact has since shot his way up to
becoming regarded as arguably the most
talented director of the show since the
beloved megumi ishitani with this
happening more and more the one piece
team has become hugely popular with the
toei studio itself with other staff in
the company looking up to them as a
result of their stellar work and so for
me there are three episodes that best
highlight this monumental achievement
the wano adaptation has become and not
just because of their sheer quality but
because the way they were made is a
byproduct of this revitalized work
environment let's look at a very popular
episode with magumi ishitani's episode
1015
it allowed animator bahi jd to have
input not just over how his scene was
composited but what colors were used too
one of the industry's best young
animators case game mori was also given
the freedom to handle the yamato and ace
flashback section alone animating and
supervising the entire eight minutes all
by himself this was the first episode i
was told to watch from this raid and to
say i was blown away by this very
installment would be a massive
understatement while i might have had
issues with how the story and the action
was paneled in the manga the manner with
which the powers that be used the source
material to create one of the most
stunningly beautiful episodes i've ever
seen committed to any given series was
nothing short of remarkable not just
providing focus on the action but
showing an attention to detail and
metaphor through its use of the yamato
scenes utterly unbelievable
[Music]
episode 1017 saw the animation director
tu yong sub personally invite a wealth
of talent across japan alongside his
equally skilled friends in china and
many others from across the world the
goal of the episode was to surpass any
that came before it and to achieve this
they were granted the freedom to use not
4 000 sheets that would typically be
used in a given episode but instead 20
000 sheets and boy does it show on
screen and lastly
in episode 1028 the aforementioned
yasunori koyama took his action
direction to new limits and took full
advantage of assassin production's
photography skills putting together a
spectacle drenched in atmospheric colors
and fascinating portrayals of power in
particular he took great care over his
use of flower petals as a visual
metaphor for the narrative of the fight
resulting in not just a feast for the
eyes but one with powerful emotional
resonance these unique additions to the
anime are something oda has said he
truly enjoys the most and it's great to
see this happen more often in an arc
where the manga version famously
off-screens or speeds through many of
its events ultimately none of these
episodes could have happened without the
complete overhaul of one piece's
production environment for many the
anime version of wano has now long since
surpassed the source material and even
for those who don't quite agree it's
impossible not to sit back and applaud
the remarkable upgrade this series has
not only seen but continues to see week
after week it's rare that an anime that
has run as long as this finds itself
better than ever but the unrelenting
passion within the team continues to
bring about new heights and i can't wait
to see how they top themselves next if
you are interested in learning more
about the people responsible for this
series i definitely recommend checking
out skippy the robot's youtube channel
he provides interesting insight into the
behind the scenes week by week and it's
a great way to find out who did your
favorite scenes and track their progress
in the industry the link is in the
description
as many of you can tell i was a massive
fan of this opening material and yet
this was around about where i started to
lose interest in the story reading week
to week would you believe that's right
for the purpose of this video i had
planned on originally reading this story
week to week but something caused me to
stop what was it and did the story
recover for me after that tune in next
week when i break down the rest of this
raid as well as its ending i can't wait
to share it all with you and don't worry
i'll make sure to talk about the yamato
stuff next time but until then i've been
toy not mark it feels great to be back
on the review train and of course thank
you so much for watching
[Music]
[Music]
foreign